- [Instructor] Let's say
we need to find a solution
to the differential equation
that the derivative of y
with respect to x is equal
to x squared over e to the y.
Pause this video and see
if you can have a go at it,
and I will give you a clue.
It is a separable differential equation.
All right, now let's do this together.
So, whenever you do any
differential equation,
the first thing you should try
to see is, is it separable?
And when I say separable,
I mean I can get all the
expressions that deal with y
on the same side as dy,
and I can separate those
from the expressions that deal with x,
and they need to be on the same
side as my differential dx.
So how can we do that?
Well, if we multiply both
sides times e to the y,
then e to the y will go
away right over here.
So we will get rid of this y expression
from the right hand side,
and then we can multiply both sides by dx.
So, if we did that, just
let me move my screen
over a bit to the left.
So I'm gonna multiply
both sides by e to the y,
and I'm also gonna multiply
both sides by dx, times dx.
And multiplying by dx gets rid
of the dx on the left hand side,
and it sits on the right
hand side with the x squared.
And so all of this is now e to the y
dy is equal to x squared,
x squared dx.
And just the fact that we
were able to do this shows
that it is separable.
Now, what we can do now is integrate
both sides of this
equation, so let's do that.
So what is the integral of e to the y dy?
Well, one of the amazing
things about the expression,
or you could say the function,
something is equal to the e to the,
and normally we say e to the x
but in this case it's e to the y,
is that the antiderivative
of this is just e to the y.
We've learned that in multiple videos.
I always express my fascination with it.
So this is just e to the y.
And likewise, if you took the derivative
of e to the y with respect
to y, it would be e to the y.
Remember, this works
because we are integrating
with respect to y here.
So the integral of e to
the y with respect to y,
well, that's e to the y.
And so that is going to be equal to
the antiderivative of x squared.
Well, that is we increment the exponent,
so that gets us to x to the third power,
and we divide by that
incremented exponent.
And since I took the indefinite
integral of both sides,
I have to put a constant on
at least one of these sides,
so let me throw it over here, so plus c.
And just to finish up,
especially on a lot of
examination, like the AP exam,
they might want you to write it in a form
where y is an explicit function of x.
So to do that, we can take
the natural log of both sides.
So we take the natural log of that side,
and we take the natural log of that side.
Well, the natural log of e to the y,
what power do we have to raise
e to to get to e to the y?
Well, that's why we took the natural log.
This just simplifies as y.
And we get y is equal to,
is equal to the natural log of
what we have right over here,
x to the third over three plus c.
And we are done.